[UPBEAT MUSIC]
MIG GERARD: I am here in Jakarta
to teach the machine learning
crash course.
DANIEL SPARING: So today
we talked about all kinds
of products we offer on Google
Cloud that help our customers
and our partners build
machine learning models.
MAYANK GARG: Really super cool.
MIG GERARD: One of the
other wonderful highlights
of teaching machine
learning is learning
about all of the
different products
that different people want to
use the machine learning for.
And those products
are so disparate--
so many different ways
to use machine learning.
MUHAMMAD GHEDDI: Do
lots of awesome stuff,
from predicting car accidents,
preventing cancer, as well
as self-driving cars.
I joined this bootcamp because
I see that we are still not
that good at early detection
of serious diseases.
[APPLAUSE]
MIG GERARD: Some of the
wonderful highlights
of any time I go to teach, but
certainly this week while I've
been teaching, are to see
the students themselves.
You can see the looks on their
faces when they're confused,
and you can come and
you can help them,
and you can see the learning
go on in their head.
And their faces are transformed.
DANIEL SPARING: I really enjoyed
working with the participants
on the Cloud AutoML, which is
a brand new product from Google
Cloud that allows you
to build your own models
on your own data sets
without writing any code.
I hope that they
will enjoy today
and they will be able
to use these tools later
in their work and their hobbies.
MUHAMMAD GHEDDI: I expect that
this program will continue,
and there will be more
students involved,
like not just professionals
can attend this event,
but also students.
MAYANK GARG: The
major thing which
I want the audience to
take away from this course
is go back and practice
as much as you can,
as you did in the class,
on the codelabs, on Kaggle,
or whatever program
you can find,
be it in your company or
a company [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER 1: Thank you!
SPEAKER 2: Thank you!
SPEAKER 3: Yay!
[APPLAUSE]